[Musique]
camia déjà cette journée qui est la
journée de la reine victoria pour
plusieurs au canada mais là ça c'est la
journée nationale des patriotes en
devoir de gratitude et de mémoire pour
ceux qui nous ont donné notre démocratie
c'est un extrait du premier ministre
bernard landry en 2002 c'est landry
d'ailleurs qui nous a quitté en novembre
dernier
c'est à ce moment là que la fête de la
reine est devenu pour le québec est la
journée nationale des patriotes je sais
qu'une certaine confusion en parle
la fête de la reine le fait de doder la
journée des patriotes on va démêler tout
ça ce matin avec gilles laporte
professeur d'histoire au cégep du
vieux-montréal sur l'apport bonjour vous
étiez vous dans le comité qui avait
tenté de convaincre bernard landry
d'instaurer la journée nationale des
patriotes
c'est une belle histoire et comme toute
belle histoire c'est une initiative
populaire
c'est des gens de l'est ce cri qui ont
lancé cette initiative un jour férié un
nouveau jour férié au départ consacré
aux patriotes et avant même de se
manifester ils ont collecté par - deux
cent mille signatures par les syndicats
des associations étudiantes et
finalement au printemps 2002 pardon ils
me contactent et 10 selon les besoins
d'un historien maintenant pourrait pour
faire un chemin supplémentaires alors
ils ont commencé des représentations
politiques on ne rencontre pas mal aux
premières fois monsieur landry et l'eau
ici qu'est et dire oui mon nouveau jour
férié c'est une fortune c'est des coûts
importants
alors c'est là qu'on a eu l'idée
pourquoi pas la reine c'est à dire qu'
il y avait un anniversaire important
1837 les patriotes lance une grande
grande assemblée publique passe fait que
démocratique populaire et c'était une
magnifique coïncidence de profiter du
doubs mois de mai pour que célébrer nos
patriotes
alors pour vous c'était très important
de célébrer
les patriotes pourquoi exactement qu'est
ce qu'on retient de leur histoire de la
rébellion d'abord rappelons le rôle des
journées mémorielle ce sont des journées
partant de la preuve on en parle ce
matin donc c'est l'occasion de faire une
littéralement une fête de l'histoire
une fête delà de la soude de la culture
une fête de l'identité une fête en somme
qui me donne l'occasion de rappeler
plusieurs pays on sort par exemple aux
états unis on le martin luther king day
c'est donc une fête des droits civiques
des droits démocratiques sous couvert
d'hommes et de femmes qui il y à 1 681
se sont battu démocratiquement puis avec
des armes afin d'obtenir des droits ou
6ème que la liberté d'expression le
droit d'élire ses représentants le droit
de contrôler ses affaires chez soit
acceptée en somme une fête qui célébrait
nos droits acquis mais en prenant appui
sur l'histoire et revenons en 2002
maintenant quand ça a été annoncé
j'imagine que ça c'est pas fait ce genre
moussel la surprise totale parce que
après avoir rencontré monsieur landry or
rien ne se passe avait commencé la
politique
puis tout à coup le 22 la vente du sang
à mi-2010 2002 par louis à saint denis
sur richelieu où on célèbre
traditionnellement la bataille de ces
2010 23 novembre sans prévenir personne
chez landry au micro annonce que plus
tôt dans la journée par décret il a
annoncé la création de la journée
nationale des sciences
nous l'avions appris à peine quelques
minutes avant son élection
oui donc qu'un sentiment immense fierté
on était on était complètement emballé
il faut savoir que maintenant il fallait
mettre de l'épaule à la roue c'est à
dire que nous étions gosses ya
maintenant c'est un fait le décret pas
d'argent pas d'autres encadrement alors
nous nous avions les artisans de cette
journée là que le travail le vrai
travail commence et pour nous imaginez
appelé des dizaines voire des centaines
d'euros québec
n'oubliez pas que désormais c'est la
journée nationale des patriotes vous
avez face à vous les voulez bien sûr
avec des citoyens des téléphones sur
votre site web vous indiquez jour de
dollars si vous indiquez jour-là elle il
faut le modifier c'est la loi monsieur
madame alors c'est un travail qu'on
poursuive pour ça c'est en maintenant
des gens le travail est à peu près
accompli oui les amis
mais arrive on se demande toujours et
c'est la fête de la reine des patriotes
on entend ça beaucoup parce que c'est
une c provincial décélérait les normes
du travail qui termine les jours fériés
alors les jours fériés bien là chaque
province est libre d'en dévier
et puisque dans les neuf autres
provinces du canada célèbre victoria des
six toujours il ya une légère confusion
mais ici tout le territoire québécois
dont aucune équivoque c'est la journée
nationale des patriotes ans avait été
reçue le changement faire passer la fête
de la reine en journée nationale des
toujours la même chose dans ces enjeux
qui concerne l'identité plus
nationalistes québécois à mi chemin
entre l'indifférence et puis là la
lecture purement politique en y voyant
un processus de nationalisme et tout le
reste toujours cette question là qui est
en filigrane dans ces angelots vous le
savez mais néanmoins on a réussi ce
travail de pédagogie qu'on s'en rappeler
d'abord que c'est une le démocratique
qui concerne tout le monde y compris aux
anglophones mais aussi les allophones
qui dans bon nombre de pays d'où ils
viennent ont vécu aussi des luttes
analogue en grèce en amérique latine
sont pas sans rappeler les écoutent nos
patriotes de 1837
merci de nous rappeler à ce pan
d'histoire ce matin vous aux étudiants
doivent retrouver vos cours très
passionnant d'ailleurs le seul apport
merci je veux juste rappeler 27 c'est
possible que pour la première fois en 17
ans aujourd'hui et ici au sommet de
l'assemblée nationale du québec le
drapeau des patriotes c'est une belle
grande initiative france qui vient
couronner ses 17 années de en hommage à
monsieur bernard landry notamment qui
fut le créateur en 2002 merci de l'avoir
souligné à juste titre merci